[Music]
once i've found an interesting lesson i
open it in the link reader
i can see how many new words there are
for me in lesson
these words are blue
as i read i click on blue words i don't
know
this shows me popular translations for
these words
these are the translations that have
been used most often by link members
this one looks good
now on to the next blue word
if i'm not happy with the popular
translations shown i can click the
available dictionaries and create my own
notice that when i add a translation the
blue words turn yellow
yellow words are called links and they
stay yellow until i've learned them
i continue until i have removed all the
blue either by creating links or making
words known
at any time if i know all remaining blue
words on a page
turning a page moves them all to known
automatically
if i accidentally move a word to known
no big deal
i just click on it to make a link with
it
when moving to the next page the
integrated vocabulary review pops up
this lets me review all yellow links
from the page before moving on
this quick step lets me quickly review
these links while they are still fresh
i continue my lesson creating links and
making words known until all blue words
are gone
when all blue words are gone i complete
the lesson
i can give the lesson a rose to
recommend it to other link members in
their feeds
now i go back and listen to the lesson
while reading along
clicking in the progress bar takes me
back to the first page quickly
at a certain point i'm ready to move on
to my next lesson
i don't need to understand the lesson
perfectly i know that it will all become
clearer over time with enough exposure
and linking
the more reading and listening i do the
fewer blue words i see and the closer i
get to fluency
happy linking